>>> TONIGHT, GROWING QUESTIONS
FOR DONALD TRUMP'S ATTORNEYS IN
THE PROBE INTO THE CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS FOUND AT MAR-A-LAGO.
REMEMBER, WE'RE WAITING ANY
MOMENT FOR THE TRUMP LEGAL TEAM
RESPONSE TO THE DOJ FILING.
IT HAS TO COME AT SOME POINT.
SOURS CONFIRMING TO CNN THAT IT
WAS CHRISTINA BOBB WHO SIGNED A
JUNE LETTER THAT SAID THAT TRUMP
TURNED OVER ALL OF THE
CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS AT
MAR-A-LAGO, THAT THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT HAD DEMANDED IN THAT
SUBPOENA.
WHICH THIS PHOTO FROM THE AUGUST
SEARCH OF MAR-A-LAGO STRONGLY
INDICATES IS A FALSE STATEMENT.
BOBB IS FAR FROM THE ONLY LAWYER
IN TRUMP'S WORLD WHO HAS FACED
LEGAL JEOPARDY.
TOM FOREMAN IS "OUTFRONT."
>> Reporter: AS THE FBI SWEPT IN
AND SEIZED ALL THOSE CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS, TRUMP ATTORNEY
CHRISTINA BOBB, WHO IS FRONT AND
CENTER DEFENDING HER CLIENT.
>> THIS RAID WAS A SHOCK TO
EVERYBODY.
THERE ARE NO CRIMES HERE.
I THINK THIS IS A LOT TO DO
ABOUT NOTHING.
>> Reporter: BUT WELL BEFORE THE
SEARCH, SHE SIGNED ANOTHER
DOCUMENT INSISTING ALL
CLASSIFIED MATERIAL HAD ALREADY
BEEN TURNED OVER.
THE DOCUMENT "THE NEW YORK
TIMES" SAID WAS CRAFTED BY
EVIDENCE RAN CORCORAN.
NEITHER HAS RESPONDED TO CNN'S
REQUEST FOR COMMENT.
ANY MEMBERS OF TRUMP'S LEGAL
TEAM, IF THEY WERE INVOLVED IN
MOVING, HIDING, OR KNEW SUCH
PAPERS WERE STILL IN MAR-A-LAGO,
COULD BE IN A BIND.
>> THEY ARE BEING LOOKED AT
POTENTIALLY FOR OBSTRUCTING THE
INVESTIGATION.
AND THEY'RE IN AN IMPOSSIBLE
POSITION.
THEY EITHER NEED TO DISAVOW OUR
CLIENT, SAYING WE WERE MISLED,
OR THEY'RE GOING TO BE
CONSIDERED COMPLICIT AND HAVE TO
FACE QUESTIONS FROM THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT.
>> MR. PRESIDENT.
>> Reporter: THE LIST OF LAWYERS
UNDER SCRUTINY WHILE ACTING ON
DONALD TRUMP'S BEHALF IS
GROWING.
>> I KNOW CRIMES.
I CAN SMELL THEM.
>> Reporter: RUDY GIULIANI IS
NOW A TARGET OF A GEORGIA PROBE
INTO WHETHER THE FORMER
PRESIDENT ILLEGALLY TRIED TO
INTERFERE WITH THE 2020
ELECTION.
ATTORNEY LYNN WOOD IS SAID TO
SPEAK TO THE GRAND JURY IN THAT
MATTER.
HE'S A STRONG TRUMP DEFENDER BUT
SAID, I DIDN'T DO ANYTHING
WRONG.
>> THIS IS BIGGER THAN PRESIDENT
TRUMP.
IT IS THE VERY ESSENCE OF OUR
REPUBLICAN FORM OF GOVERNMENT,
AND IT HAS TO BE DONE.
>> Reporter: JOHN EASTMAN, THE
ALLEGED ARCHITECT OF THE PLAN TO
OVERTURN THE RESULTING IN
CONGRESS, AND JEFFREY CLARK HAVE
BOTH DRAWN THE INTEREST OF
FEDERAL INVESTIGATORS.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP WON BY A
LANDSLIDE.
WE ARE GOING TO PROVE IT.
>> Reporter: SIDNEY POWELL AND A
HALF DOZEN MORE PRO TRUMP
LAWYERS WERE SANCTIONED FOR
FILING WHAT A JUDGE CALLED
FRIVOLOUS LAWSUITS CONTESTING
THE ELECTION.
AND MICHAEL COHEN, UNLIKE THE
OTHERS WHO ALL DENY WRONGDOING,
HE WAS ACTUALLY CHARGED WITH
CRIMES, INCLUDING CAMPAIGN
FINANCE VIOLATIONS.
HE ADMITTED IT, LOST HIS LAW
LICENSE, AND WENT TO PRISON.
>> MY LOYALTY TO MR. TRUMP HAS
COST ME EVERYTHING.
>> Reporter: TO BE CLEAR,
DEFENDING A CLIENT IS LEGAL,
EVEN IF THAT CLIENT HAS
COMMITTED A CRIME.
INDEED, IT IS AN ATTORNEY'S
DUTY.
BUT POTENTIALLY HELPING A CLIENT
COMMIT A CRIME CAN QUICKLY MAKE
A LAWYER NEED A LAWYER, TOO.
POPPY?
>> THAT'S EXACTLY RIGHT.
TOM, THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
"OUTFRONT" NOW, JOHN DEAN,
FORMER NIXON WHITEOUT COUNSEL.
JOHN, YOU KNOW BETTER THAN
ANYONE WHAT THE RULES ARE FOR
LAWYERS WHEN THEY SIGN DOCUMENTS
LIKE THIS.
DO YOU THINK TRUMP'S ATTORNEY,
CHRISTINA BOBB, COULD BE IN
LEGAL JEOPARDY NOW?
>> IT SIMPLY APPEARS THAT WAY.
WE KNOW FROM THAT LETTER SHE
SIGNED THE CERTIFICATION.
SHE DID RELY ON OTHERS.
SHE REPORTS IN THAT
CERTIFICATION AND WE DON'T KNOW
WHAT AMOUNT OF EFFORT SHE PUT
INTO IT.
BUT SHE'S AT HIGH RISK SIGNING A
DOCUMENT LIKE THAT, IF SHE'S NOT
PUT SOME EFFORT INTO IT.
THAT'S WHAT CAN CAUSE HER
JEOPARDY.
>> AS I MENTIONED, YOU WERE THE
WHITE HOUSE COUNSEL FOR
PRESIDENT NIXON.
BUT YOUR DECISION TO NOT HELP
NIXON COVER UP HIS ROLE IN
WATERGATE PLAYED A HUGE ROLE IN
TAKING HIM DOWN.
YOU PUBLICLY TESTIFIED AND
COOPERATED WITH THE
INVESTIGATION.
OF COURSE, YOU TOLD NIXON THAT
THERE WAS A CANCER GROWING ON
THE PRESIDENCY AND IT NEEDED TO
BE REMOVED.
WHAT COULD YOU ADVISE CHRISTINA
BOBB TO DO?
>> POPPY, I TAUGHT A COURSE
BEFORE THE PANDEMIC HIT ALL OVER
THE COUNTRY TO ALERT ATTORNEYS
TO WHAT THEY SHOULD LOOK FOR,
BECAUSE I DID GET ACROSS THE LAW
FOR A BRIEF TIME AND REGRETTED
IT AND TRIED INTERNALLY TO GET
MY COLLEAGUES TO DO THE RIGHT
THING.
SO THERE WERE SOME 45 LAWYERS IN
WATERGATE THAT GOT ON THE WRONG
SIDE OF THE LAW.
SO I TOOK THAT KNOWLEDGE AND
TRAVELLED THE COUNTRY AND TRIED
TO EXPLAIN TO OTHERS YOU CAN
VERY EASILY SLIDE ACROSS THE
LINE.
PARTICULARLY WHEN YOU HAVE A
POWERFUL CLIENT, A POWERFUL
FIGURE, IT IS JUST NOT A GREAT
STEP TO AGREE TO DO SOMETHING
THAT YOU LATER REALIZE YOU
SHOULDN'T HAVE DONE.
NOW, I DON'T KNOW IF THERE HAVE
BEEN VIOLATIONS OF THE LAW BY
THE ATTORNEYS.
IT CERTAINLY APPEARS THEY HAVE
JEOPARDY.
IF THEY DIDN'T KNOW BEFORE THEY
HAVE PROBLEMS, THEY CERTAINLY
KNOW FROM REPORTING IN THE LAST
SEVERAL WEEKS THAT OTHERS ARE
LOOKING AT THIS CERTAINLY THINK
THEY DO HAVE PROBLEMS.
THAT MEANS THEY SHOULD PROBABLY
RECUSE THEMSELVES